this race from i i'd be curious from
your perspective
uh what happened with this race um
where certainly
i was part of the race uh you know i
don't think i had much to do
but much to do with um with some of like
the
uh the state wins and losses uh down the
stretch since it it seems like a lot of
it came down to south carolina and some
other places
um so if you remember the dnc then you
remember when pete
buddha judge ran for head of the dnc oh
yeah
i was supporting ellison at the time
congressman ellison was my candidate
yeah so when you saw you probably saw
pete speak
uh to the dnc at various times like was
there an inkling then it's like
this guy this guy's gonna run for
president in a hot minute
where is any sets of that i heard those
those rum rumblings i mean for me i
didn't i didn't give it a thought
i mean i was laser focused on
congressman keith ellison but now that i
think back on it yeah i do remember
people
saying saying that he had that that
that itch so to speak yeah so i wasn't
surprised to see him run
um so the bernie 2020 campaign
um there was a period when i thought
bernie was gonna win the race
um i think a lot of people did um you
know like that
when you looked at it i mean um bernie
and pete were
essentially the co-winners coming out of
iowa depending upon how you look at it
um and then everything you know how i
look at it
we won iowa go ahead go ahead yeah well
for what it's worth for what it's worth
i tweeted the same you know i was like i
think bernie won
iowa now let's see like go on to the
next one you know it's just because i
thought it's like well the man
you know man got more votes um that's it
the popular seat but you see how he
changed the rules
and you know open up pandora's box on
that see the popular vote
that doesn't didn't count for our
campaign at the time they changed the
rules on us
in iowa but uh we went on to make
history we won the first three contests
technically you know i mean that was a
big deal
and we still were ripped off by the
media
there was a head of steam so you you win
iowa and i said as much when new
hampshire which people expected but it
was still a
a romper and then coming out of nevada
it was like bernie i you know and i was
quoted as saying it too i was like it's
a great chance bernie like runs the
table here
um so tell me about those days because
i've been
now part of my own campaign and you have
like a head of steam momentum
when things don't go well uh it you feel
like
you're on like this is what i felt like
oh this first time i've described it
this way let's see if it works
um so you you know those medieval movies
when they're like a bunch of people on
horse like you know like a braveheart
type charge or like this
that's what it felt like when you're on
like the campaign trail you're like
riding and you know
doing rallies and all these people
volunteering for it for your campaign
and energizing you
and then when things go poorly um in a
race it feels
like that scene in that movie when like
the horses fall
like there's like this you know uh
pit and then like the horse is going oh
and then like you're all like sort of
um on the ground and everyone's
scrambling around and like you know
people are
um like uh getting stabbed
right left at least that's the way the
movie goes uh
so so that that's where things go poorly
um but when things are going well
it feels like you're never gonna lose it
feels like we've got the wind at our
back
and everything's going our way and uh we
will not be denied i'd love to hear
what it was like from your perspective
uh like heading in and out of iowa in
the early states
it's almost an indescribable feeling
especially since i was with the senator
in 2016
and just to see that kind of momentum i
felt as though
the seeds we planted as i reflected
state by state i i felt like the seeds
we planted in 2016 were bearing fruit
in 2020 that's how it felt and
it just it was it's like a snowball
rolling down a a mountain right here
you're picking up that
picking up that that pace and rolling
fast and building building building
and by the time we got to nevada and
when those results came in because i was
the one
in nevada and i stayed there to give the
you know the speech to the
to our supporters in person there
on the senator's behalf and i mean it
was smoking you hear me because what
nevada proved because remember
yang all the naysayers said oh yeah iowa
is white
totally disregarding the black people
and other people of color that live in
that state
but i digress new hampshire is white
so again totally bernie's neighboring
state right
so they'd be like oh nothing nothing it
didn't mean anything
you know but when we got to nevada baby
they couldn't deny it they couldn't deny
the diversity
and he won especially young people
you know the african-american community
our hispanic community he won
communities of color in nevada along
with our white
uh sisters and brothers so he couldn't
be denied and to me
i think that is the moment when the
neoliberal when the power structure of
the democratic party decided
we got to put a stop to this i really do
believe that and south carolina
did us in and it wasn't enough time
between south carolina and the other
states
for us to re to regroup i have never
seen an endorsement
have an impact like jim clyburn coming
out for joe biden in south carolina that
was
unbelievable it was like someone had
just taken
like a um like a
pin out of a dyke or a dam or something
like that where all of a sudden clyburn
was like i'm for joe and then all of a
sudden whoosh like
this freaking tide of uh voters in south
carolina followed his lead
um i genuinely think that that one
endorsement changed the course of
the nomination and the race entirely the
course of history really
you you feel that way imagine how we
felt when i tell you we worked
extraordinarily hard in that state we
worked harder in that state than the
biden campaign i know that unequivocally
we were in that state early we didn't
take anything for granted
we had people coming in and out of that
state our national surrogates people who
you and i both admire
like dr cornell west made several trips
to that state
brother you know to let the weapon
himself danny glover who was beloved
across
generations he even drove yeah
brother danny glover drove from one end
of south carolina to the
other drove himself he would be in that
state sometimes when even
i wasn't i adopted that state even
though i traveled all over the country
i visited south carolina more than any
other state
going to all kinds of events bringing
people in susan sarandon
tim robbins i mean you name it in and
out
all age groups philip agnew from the
dream defenders who i know you know
i mean just from from millennials to
boomers to gen
x's you name it we put so much effort
and that south carolina team
worked so hard and we knew our backs
were against the wall
so although we it didn't have the
outcome that we wanted
we worked and didn't take it for granted
and you're absolutely right when
congressman clyburn came up in there
it totally turned that entire thing
around you know vice president
biden up until that point had never won
the primary and all the times he had run
for president until that
particular moment and then the
coalescing of everybody else on that
ticket
you might not necessarily agree with me
but when you got the number two
candidate in the race
so far drop out and endorse you know
vice president biden you got
senator klobuchar did the same thing
others did
hey that was it that was all she wrote
and
then covet hit two so you got all of
that
plus covet bam
end of our end of our our run
uh i feel your pain um
i was trying to describe that sort of
the charge like the high of feeling like
you're gonna
win um and then that dispiriting
uh uh
feeling that you can't describe to when
you realize you might not win or when
you realize like oh my gosh like as hard
as we fought
and scratched and clawed here in south
carolina to try and win every vote
uh you know it it may not go our way uh
it's why we in some ways
uh do what we do where the only way you
can succeed
um in this kind of politics and activism
is if you're putting your heart and soul
into it or else
it's impossible that's one thing that
people don't appreciate fully
where they think it's like oh you could
be doing it for um you know some kind of
self-serving reason it's like you try
doing this for any length of time
but for any reason other than the fact
that you genuinely
are trying to um to
fulfill like a vision that someone else
has or you have or think you can improve
people's way of life because
it's uh and so you put your heart and
soul and energy into it and then when it
doesn't go your way it's
devastating it is so hard uh to just
like pick yourself up after that and be
like well you know that like especially
in your case because
you'd been grinding it out for years
five years
when the senator created our revolution
as you know after 2016
and and i got the opportunity to run
that organization in iran again so yes
five years and five years i've i i
physically touched down in almost 50
states
i think there are only three states that
i did not physically go
to over the last wow
yeah i gave it my all yeah really we
know you did nina
i mean it it's why you have so much uh
admiration among
so many of us is that we know you're a
warrior and that you've been
uh fighting the fight uh on the ground
in the air
on the airwaves like wherever it needs
to be fought like now
in your in your earbuds nina's got a
podcast that i'm gonna go on in a minute
um hello somebody is the podcast
hello somebody there we go thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you